hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play don't
starve okay before we get started I have
to tell you this story um I was I got up
early this morning and I was browsing
reddit you know just looking at cat
pictures funny stuff on the internet and
catching up on some news and I come
across this video and the video is
titled woman moving her butt cheeks to
the beat of Beethoven and I go hey yes I
want to see that click and the video
opens up is this real classy place I
mean everyone was dressed nice even the
woman on stage I mean she was pantsless
but I mean - still classy on the left
she had this big masters piano jacket on
and she was sitting on this piano vest
she was she saw fur on the back so it
wasn't like lewd or anything was real
highbrow stuff and everyone else you
could see in the video was kind of
confused like what's going on what
what's happening what's happening here I
don't know what's going on in and all
sudden she makes like she's gonna play
the piano and then she lifts up her the
dovetail on her coat and spreads it out
so you can get a better view and there's
this little bowtie like right above her
butt crack a table and I'm looking at
this looking at the most ridiculous
thing I've ever seen in my life and the
whole room goes silent and everyone's
like quiet down you hear and see ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha donar on that are on da
da da dun dun
Dalila who's the funny video I've ever
seen in my great best way to get up in
the morning bar none there's nobody ha I
watched every minute it was fantastic
amazing performance would pay to see
that in real life anyway alright
oh this stupid story to tell anyway I've
been playing around a little more in
another world just to try to get a
better idea what I'm doing I didn't get
very far I started wandering through
this swamp with like nothing there and
everything was trying to kill me in
swamp so what lesson I learned from that
is don't go into the swamp up piss
monkeys it's it's already evening well
this is stupid all these are berries
here and I learned that you can cook the
berries and lemon law you can get extra
food that way man owner of that lady has
more performances like if that's her
thing if that's how she makes a living
she goes around cities in America and
just I don't even know if it was in
America it might have been Europe or
something or some other country but III
it tickles me the thought that she goes
around all around the world and just
does that for a living and people pay to
see that I would pay to see that that
swamp there also I learned that I have a
map I need to go up north into this area
cuz that's where that's where most of
the gold is I need to go get gold
because I need to make my science
machine and wibbly-wobbly will evolve it
anything looks like that yep yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah up up up
now all you're gonna be like I gotta
find Matt video I got that fine I'm not
gonna link it cuz you know it's not safe
for work I mean it's fine you can't
literally can't see anything besides
someone's butt and if you think
someone's butt is really that bad then
you need to get a life but that that was
the funniest video I've ever seen in my
life I've never I'm well I mean I've
seen some pretty funny videos not mine
of course my my videos are
bottom-of-the-barrel entertainment
anyways but just just the fact that I
saw this if I'd have known it was night
I would have told this story during the
night save myself in time but for now
I'll just kind of add fuel to the fire
and
we're gonna wait here until it passes so
okay it's finally day car bird oh sorry
for that hope you enjoyed my little show
in the meantime anyway I need to make
another pickaxe cuz this one cube is
just about broken yeah get rid of that
just trap it don't eat it they'll need
to gotta go find me some gold also I
learned that you run faster when you're
on the road well there's no gold here
what is this crap I'm not going in there
that looks like oh that's just normal
for us
well not normal forest if anything in
this game was normal we'd be playing a
totally different game probably be
playing minecraft or something well
worth it dingdong damn is what happened
here
here's a shovel I could awfully I could
use that I didn't die here I haven't
died yet in this play oh there's like
nothing left in that
shut up beehive I'm not going near that
ah let's be everywhere why never seen be
before my life
what the hell is going on alright nother
Road no burger mmm ririn okay I need to
find some gold gold gold gold gold it's
wood gold I tell you fool gold maybe I
should have gone more north I see rocks
I gotta go back because that there that
thing I think mostly anyway you find the
gold in the fields I thought that's
where I found the rocks and that's where
I see rocks on my map so I'd imagine
that that's where dude your dough to be
no don't be get out of here B I don't
need no honey I need some food though
roasted berries
mmm fill me up good and I got carrot ah
shuttle roasted my carrots anyway that's
not a euphemism for anything
I still got that video stuck in my head
like I'm gonna have to go back and watch
it again just cuz it was such a great
performance I loved every second of it
you all need to see it yo everyone
should see that video everyone should go
see your show alright
know that I got to find me some coal biz
I can't carry any more what are you
talking about what you're talking about
where to go oh um I don't need the torch
let's go white light the whole forest on
fire oh it's not even lit okay ah run
away
come on my wait bird do you see the bird
just landed in front of me to lock my
path okay so I can't get gold from this
I might as well mine it I guess I need
gold
I need gold there's some berries over
here let me pick him real quick let me
pick him real quick
actually you know what I'm just gonna
skip ahead so I don't waste you guys
this time I'm just gonna go ahead until
I find some gold how about that how
about that
okay see you in a bit bye Gold I didn't
even notice it who's staring me right in
the face I found it ah no no I burn you
killed me last time I won't take your
egg I'm not trying to take your egg I
swear I have a grass suit Donna I didn't
mean the big night off I got a gold I
got one gold I want more gold though I
can't get away from this guy though go
ahead and take your egg I didn't take
your a thank you wha
Turkey alright so I gotta go bye bye
rabbits
okay anyway so where's my camp well my
calves are marked on the map I guess I
don't need to do it anyway I'm actually
gonna make my camp count on the edge of
this forest here because it's an awfully
nice location there's the gold right
next to it and I'm able to uh there's
also lots of turkeys apparently whenever
you pick a berry bush
you get turkeys that's a nice thing
that's a real nice feature that smell
that blablabla blablabla
rah rah rah what are you doing haha you
walked right into my science machine
hooray hey I will put that on the ground
I'll eat that in a second I gotta
protect my stuff here
normal campfire is fine
apparently people don't like my size
machine I don't know why seems awfully
nice to me but whatever all right so I
got the science machine which means that
I can generate structures all right hey
wall segments I need to research them
for breakdowns objects into their
scientific components what does that
even mean
prototype a shovel I know I can't carry
any more stuff okay so anyway I just
what am I doing here
cook this up cuz this ought to be real
good eating mmm
it was it was good eatin
is there like a storage thing that I
could do cuz I mean I got that shovel
there little better than the shovel that
I have right now but anyway is that
morsel give me that morsel these things
do not give a lot of food when like just
normal berries give tons rump come on up
all right we're good
it's just to get rid of this shovel with
that right there okay um how we doing
how we doing how we doing let's see how
we're doing we can make we make anything
new what is this a pitchfork move the
ground up shave the dirty beatnik beard
no way no way that we got there's a lot
of stuff that you can build I imagine
this it was oh I got your back swish woo
why am I talking like this woo I don't
know I need to make a farm now so let's
prototype on fall I can't
I need more grass and then manure and
you guys said that a key box mmm there's
one more of these key I can build no I
don't need that I don't need that and
it's about night time okay so we're
gonna fast forward in time here until
the next day bear with me
okay we're back
um I don't exactly know what I'm doing
but I sprouted a beard but I can
actually make grass this pitchfork is
kind of interesting I can actually
change the landscape here don't exactly
know what that's for just yet but
eventually I will so I'm gonna keep that
in mind for later but I've got sort of a
home base here I'm gonna try to remember
where it is and we got more gold over
there that we can get but just that
stupid son of a gun over there blocking
my path I'm just getting some more wood
so that when I relocate I can go make
your campfire if I need to if I'm stuck
over there in the other area I want to
have wood let him know you know who I am
anyway so we got more wood we got a
beard looking good the description of
this guy did save it this guy could grow
quite a magnificent beard I don't need
that's wasted space no don't drop it
just plant it planted trees make the
strangest noises when they change I
really don't like it I'm Mexican I
quickly equip the gold the are the pick
so I can get this gold real quick it's
just cuz all this gold is centered
around the egg here and it's really
annoying oh no you didn't see anything
yes here they ah one strike
ha ha ha what is that it's a does am i
dying no no no I can't die now oh I've
got too much good stuff go away go let
me alone thank you please there's gonna
fight that spider now I hope so oh I'm
going through all my food I might as
well cook my carrots I guess
cuz I think I think they give a little
extra if you cook I'm I'm not sure I
don't know I don't know how this game
works
you think I'm and I think they spoil
because that green that green line has
been going down for a while why do we
need a bank-owned I don't want to buy a
gown I don't want any my own I just got
to hit this one more time and then I'll
be able to get the gold come on come on
donk
there we go gold nuggets good for me all
right running away
look at the food over there I don't want
that though there's a gold mine over
here if you can just go away please
that's right that's right eff right off
if Alf cuz this way I can have enough
stuff to make another science machine if
I wanted them relocate so I should be
good but I still need a fire manure
isn't that a weird thing I got I got a
fine manure ah damn it I've been here
for days I can't possibly think the word
to get manure you market buyer that's
gross it's the truth don't question it
it's the truth you know it's true
come on this is real life simulator here
what are you thinking what do you think
if you still don't know what I'm talking
about then come on pick up on the hands
come on
you're stupid either way I shouldn't I
shouldn't be calling my viewers stupid
so I'm - I'm so sorry I'm not sorry I
don't know where we're going but I don't
know where to find manure because I
haven't even seen any sort of a giant
buffalo that you guys have said that
there were so I don't know who berries
mmm I love me some berries seed me some
carrots Oh actually deep berries are
about to spoil so all I need to do that
probably need to do that
other than what is that oh man it's too
strong I remember seeing that before but
then I died before I could find it you
owe gold what is this miner's hat whoa
what no nice nice man
it's nice real nice or dead guy though I
don't care I'm such a badass I don't
care about anyone other than me yeah my
way get rid Rock I got a miner's hat
tell mess with me damn it it's almost
evening the day does not last long
enough I'm actually getting close to
swampland which I do not like it's just
a little patch up there so I should be
fine
this looks like a good place for a camp
but I'll think about that later it's
much much much later damn it is it just
a peninsula we go up up up up up up up
up up up run faster you douche I
shouldn't be calling my guy a douche but
he's a douche anyway whom are gold I
like more gold I parently I found the
entire gold mine just sitting here
except no ding dong damn anything I got
too much Flintstone I guess the next
time I set up I can make it more
permanent like camp thingy shut up I'll
tell you when it's late oh the mining
handle he'll be at night cuz I can see
I've got my own portable light
oh no it's running out of durability by
either way this is still really cool hey
man it's just a peninsula here there's
nothing here this is a tiny Kyle it's
nothing maybe farther south I don't know
let me go south I want to know where
I'll go south and then I'll make a I
don't know this might actually be able
to last me through the night I have no
idea Oh found a road well let me go I'm
so fast oh damn it
what is it whoa hey that's my name oh
that's not it that's not a good sign
let's dig cuz why not sugar took in mine
there was a red gem sugar took some
wires shook it took up more wires I
guess I can use that to make some pretty
interesting
Dragic ghost hahaha
now gold more gold down there why is our
gold everywhere why why uh I probably
shouldn't be grave-digging at night
probably not the best possible solution
a gnome a lawn gnome I think did I find
one of those before I think I did and it
was supposed to increase my sanity or
something it's almost night but I still
got some time
woohoo is that a creepy fog growing in
across the cemetery I'm so scared
chugga-chugga Nancy here lies some guy
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
milkers hey that's my name again this
ghost ever gonna leave me alone god I
hope so
I think I gotta get on the road to get
away from it uh-oh
no what is this I don't want an evil
flower I'm not gonna eat that
screw that seriously look at that box
thing leave do you
Keeble flowers alone is this thing I'm
gonna look at alone ah ghosts
my visions going wibbly-wobbly I gotta
make a campfire soon but I can't because
I can't get away from the damn ghost I'm
just gonna run really I'm just gonna run
for it just running for it running
straight away from it okay it's almost
night so I almost got to pack it in oh
man my sanity is dropping bad no not you
now yeah now spiders there's a lot of
gold here though okay I'm Nick's gonna
I'm not doing so good so my sanity is
actually really low so I'm gonna make a
fire a big campfire fire pit yeah add
some fuel to that hopefully no goes what
is that I see the wires I uh uh
it's a flower bottle take your sanity go
up okay so things do spoil what is that
guy guy oh hey what is those things what
is they what is those things alright
gonna zoom forward a bit my sanity is
obviously dropping so I'm starting to
hallucinate
some random monsters everywhere go away
please I do not want any yeah I'm not
doing so good oh the lawn gnomes that's
right I can put Londos now lawn gnomes
down wait hang on I got it how do i what
do I do
we'll be some kind of religious artifact
I don't think so buddy
how do I get only one over here
apparently I just drop all three they're
supposed to increase your sanity in some
way right oh man my I need to pick some
flowers with some woods okay there's
some woods out here that I can get some
nice flowers hopefully I'll remember
what yeah the campfire is actually
marked on my map I know there's a lot of
gold here that I'm missing but I need to
go pick me some flowers dark petals
that's not what I want that's not what I
want what is jumping wormhole heck yes
ah that was not a sane thing to do yeah
okay I'm even more damaged than I was
before where am I No maybe that was a
big mistake
probably flowers help my sanity I'm not
doing well help please help I'm
apparently in a whole new world because
my map is now entirely new but I'm
hoping that I can take the UH the thing
back
there's picking berries make me go up in
the sanity levels I think so nope okay
anyway ah it's a giant shadow thingy
there's plenty of stuff over here so
I'll be able to pick up my sanity pretty
soon so don't worry about me get a
pretty little butterfly mmm so nice hmm
eat that raw flour more flowers it's
weird
why was picking flowers make your sanity
go I guess it's something normal and
nice to do but at the same time I don't
think it'd really help in the long run
well unless I can make an invisible
friend and named him Wilson out of a
volleyball or something I don't think
I'm gonna be any better you do what you
can to survive I guess
flowers butterflies hello haha I
murdered that butterfly why hahaha my
sanity go down again
come on the eyes okay Everett iris iris
don't take ignore me I'm I'm just going
crazy right I've got a lot of stuff here
like a box thing that I don't know what
I think it is anyway I need to do some
here lots of goodies said I'm getting
but I still need to do something I need
more sticks and grass I've been
collecting them at all Oh what is wrong
with my life what did I do to deserve
this
I'm just an old man actually I don't
know how this will hold this guy is I'm
just a middle aged man actually I think
he's younger than that I'm I'm just a
young man fit and in his 20s look at me
stop please you can handle it okay the
sanity is getting back to some sort of
normal and I'm in this new area I don't
know where it is but I got plenty of
gold and stone so I could make another
science machine if I wanted to I guess
look at that I'm almost sane now
apparently digging up Graves is a bad
idea
and sticking around the ghost for like
10 hours is also a bad idea okay anyway
that's just me what does no my heart no
it turned into a straw hat I don't know
how but it did hahahahaha
what all right whatever I'm not gonna
question anymore logic in this game just
cuz I don't want to I'll Drive myself
insane uh-uh totally in tain hua
okay enough of that mana bees dimer na
da da oh just farmer believed was this
guy's name was Wilson right I thought it
was anyway alright so there's a lot of a
lot of grass area which is kind of nice
for me but I am actually stretching way
over the time limit here so I'm gonna
cut it here so thank you all so much for
watching I J I'm gonna I'm gonna save it
quick go to the main menu because that
way I don't run out of tiny stuff so
thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video
but
Oh
boy